bonjour makatea when i was dead merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france vous êtes
en direct alors les bureaux de vote ont
fermé en nouvelle calédonie le
dépouillement a commencé at il une
tendance qui se dégage selon vous il ya
une tendance assez forte par rapport à
2018 au niveau de la participation
puisque donc on se retrouve aux
alentours de 80% à 17 heures donc à 6%
de plus que 2018 las pour le moment on
n'a pas d'autres chiffres encore mais
c'est certain que ya un taux de
participation à ces as été important
voilà un taux de participation élevé qui
montre donc l'intérêt bien évidemment
les habitants de la nouvelle calédonie
pour ce référendum
on a l'impression que les résultats
risque quand même d'être très serré on
sait qu'en 2018 le non l'avait emporté
est ce que vous pensez voilà que les
choses risquent d'être un petit peu plus
compliqué
cette fois ci et que le nom n'affiche
pas un résultat comme le premier
référendum
moi je pense qu'il va y avoir aussi en
tout cas je pense qu'il va y avoir assez
serré qu est ce qui concerne des les
partisans du oui il ya eu beaucoup de
mobilisations et des partis qui se sont
abstenus en 2018 ont maintenant rejoint
j'allais dire la tendance
majoritaire l'indépendantiste et que par
conséquent ça devrait se traduire dans
les résultats lui maintenant c'est assez
difficile de prévoir vraiment qui sera
vainqueur en tout cas c'est certain que
war logo si ceux là qui sait si c'est
l'une des parties qui se sera à quelques
pourcentages près par rapport à la
majorité donc on leur a trop coulé deux
blocs à la sortie de ce règlement alors
on sait que c'est le non l'emporté
nouvelle concertation est prévue d'ici
2022 sont les accords de nouméa mais si
le oui l'emporté quel sera l'avenir de
la nouvelle calédonie mais de toute
façon c'était prévu dans le cadre de
l'accord de nouméa
c'est à dire que si le oui l'emporté il
ya transfert des compétences de
souveraineté les compétences régaliennes
nick rhodes partie des des compétences
j'allais dire de développer en interne
ont été transférés dans la première
génération de transfert tout l'accord de
nouméa le référendum va autoriser cissé
lô oui le transfert des compétences
régaliennes de souveraineté et donc la
reconstruction d'un d'une indépendance
et la fin du processus de décolonisation
qui a été engagé au travers de l'accord
de nouméa
donc c'est certain que si le oui
l'emporté ni bien les gens les
indépendantistes que nous sommes nous
avons déjà préparé des choses on n'est
pas resté inactif et quand même et puis
on l'a déjà certaines choses et on part
pas de rien on ne parle pas de bien on a
déjà tout cette histoire toute cette
économie tout ce qui reste à faire c'est
de ré ré orienter les choses de façon à
reconstruire un nouveau thé quand ce que
l'on souhaiterait c est comme je le
disais la vision indépendantistes dans
la construction du pays
c'est une vision du destin commun je
rappelle que si
à volonté de bien commun qui est s'est
traduite dans l'accord de nouméa c'est
bien parce que à un moment donné c'est
le peuple kanak au moment des accords de
la ville des mains de la ville des
roches qui a ouvert la possibilité aux
autres communautés victimes de
l'histoire de la colonisation de pouvoir
rejoindre le monde kanak est de
construire ensemble t et d'y vivre
ensemble c'est sur cette base là que le
destin commun a été hâtée donc de
l'accord de nouméa
donc on va aller pour lui nous en tout
cas ce qui n'est de papa avec l'ensemble
des communautés
en tout cas les calédoniens vont être
fixés sur leur sort dans quelques heures
une fois le dépouillement des bureaux de
vote est terminé merci beaucoup ma ktm
et les oies d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
je rappelle que vous êtes président de
l' ong construire notre pays en malaisie
ex candidat ou 124 et aux législatives
de 2017